hey gang it's your old pals uncle hank
and kippy just want to thank you for
tuning in to ru garbage
yeah guys make sure you subscribe that
way you get the episode as they come out
you can also go to gasdigitalnetwork.com
use promo code ayg
to get bonus content and get the
episodes before they come out and hd
streaming
do it yeah welcome to another exciting
edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy
individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan
and h foley oh baby
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage
the show where we sit down with your
favorite comedians and find out if they
grow up classy
or if they're complete trash i'm your
host holy coming at you on a beautiful
day here at gas digital studios gas
digital network
here in the big studio in the heart of
the east village
i want to thank everybody for coming out
again to the live show in philly we
appreciate you guys we love you guys
thank you for supporting the podcast my
co-host
who you know and who you love all right
he is the uh the brains behind the
operation
he cooks the books he keeps the feds off
our back ladies and gentlemen
do yourself a favor the next time you
reach for a best pal you go ahead and
make it a kippy he tastes great he's
less filling
and now comes in a hard seltzer which is
very nice kevin james ryan ladies and
gentlemen hey what's up gang thanks so
much for tuning in
as always we appreciate all the support
as we get this off the ground we're
currently in the top 200 on itunes so
please rate review
subscribe all that jazz keep us moving
up we appreciate it
um and full video available on youtube
you can subscribe there as well
and also if you want you can sign up for
gasdigitalnetwork.com use promo code ayg
you save a couple of bucks we get to wet
our beak a little bit it's a win-win for
everybody
sign up we appreciate it yes sir and
gang we could not and i say
could not be more happy to have our
incredibly special guest here with us
today
as an actor he has appeared in twin
peaks sidekick with matt mira
corporate wine country kerber enthusiasm
his thin
comedian he's appeared on the bonfire
he's appeared on the late late show
twice he is live at gotham
date night he has his own comedy central
prevents presents
you've seen him on all things comedy
live at midnight this is not happening
the late last late call with carson daly
the today's show
he's had four appearances on kona which
we just said before the show started
has one of the best late night
appearances of all time
with his wrong number story absolutely
fantastic
you've seen him on the church of what's
happening now but the big question in
his mind today
is he garbage pre-show he was sipping on
a thai tea and eating some rice noodles
so he's coming up classy off the jump
ladies and gentlemen do me a favor
give me a big [ __ ] round of applause
for the one the only mr j
larson everybody
look at him got the bookshelf the old
record player
[ __ ] class
class for life first of all let me ask
you this how can does anyone not like
youtube clowns
[Laughter]
talk to my girlfriend yeah i don't know
we're two [ __ ] dirtbags from philly
you know it's
i don't know where are you coming at us
from are you out there in hollywood and
la la land
yeah i'm in l.a i just want to say kevin
did say in the intro
we get to wet our beak
so i don't i don't know when you retired
and moved to south florida but i just
think it's great
hey you guys i'm in that sorry wait you
can go
no i was just saying you know what time
very nice you got your thai tea
uh what is the back story of jay larson
now where did you grow up where are you
from tell us the whole story
i grew up in massachusetts just outside
of boston stoneham mass okay
homer nancy kerrigan i'm very nice i'll
throw that in your face
that's better than tanya harding yeah oh
my god right
but kerrigan kind of turned out to be
kind of a piece of [ __ ] a little bit
didn't she let me tell you something bro
all right first of all don't invite me
on your show
and then start ripping into stoneham
massachusetts royalty
yeah dude that's legacy he won she won
two medals for this country
and in the midst of it a co-worker tried
to
beat her down all right a co-worker
allegedly allegedly she was not involved
from what from the reports i read
okay good point good point um
yeah stoner mass i'll tell you this
right now it was very interesting when
when you guys reached out because i i've
been seeing like friends do your podcast
and i love the idea
because i'm going to tell you this it's
going to be interesting to see where we
turn out with this today because
i think when i was born
i was supposed to become class
okay but then my trajectory
i'm sorry i'm sorry no you i was saying
i have a theory on you
i think you're pretty i think you uh
you're like i think you're
you're classy like an italians like i
think you carry yourself a lot of
respect you dress very well
i think you're probably a good tipper
you probably you know you're probably
like a good
a party host and stuff like that i feel
i feel like you take care of the details
probably make a nice charcuterie plate i
would have to imagine
boys for a minute when things were slow
about eight years ago i i tried to sell
cheese boards that i was making out of
reclaimed wood
with wood that i got out of a a barn
that was built in the 1700s in michigan
all right yeah i throw a nice [ __ ]
bike
but you know what i do i come in i went
to this dinner party right so our
friends would
i love it i like my friends our friends
would do dinner parties
where they would invite people to like
everyone would do a course
right oh nice oh it's classy and and
then they would vote at the end like who
had the best
friends they they've been doing it and
they invited me and my wife
uh to go do it right and they gave us
cheese course like it's your first time
i'm just gonna give you cheese course
and i was like okay yeah
[ __ ] come at me you're gonna already
show me disrespect out the gate
i'm gonna knock this out of the [ __ ]
park
i build a cheeseboard this giant
it's all reclaimed to it with an inlaid
butcher block and then
inlaid slate which i finished
i made two loaves of bread from scratch
one
one i cut down and made crostinis out of
it
and then put together the charcuterie
and then like with chalk on the side
would point arrows to like the meats the
cheese named them all oh
nice we get in there everyone's like who
the [ __ ] are these
and then where the tr the trash side
comes out of me is
every course that someone else came with
i would go
like this one guy did a piece of bread
with a cracked egg on it that was
poached and it was
lovely right and i go man this is
unbelievable you got to give me the
bread recipe
and i knew he didn't make that breakfast
[Music]
and he would go because he doesn't see
the star he doesn't know what's coming
out of him
oh no i didn't i didn't make the bread
and i would go oh
ah oh sorry oh
and what was the name of this uh of the
uh self-sustaining organic farm that you
got the egg from
oh you got it at the supermarket you're
a piece of [ __ ] oh okay i didn't see
that coming
anyway we won that one
they bumped us to salad course we
crushed that
[Laughter]
you showed up with a caesar
dude i showed up with a chopped salad
and you're gonna be like jay what's
unique about a chopped salad i'll tell
you something
cowboy chows in scottsdale
in old town there's this restaurant and
they do this chopped salad
and like we copped the recipe we dried
sweet corn we did all this
i mean dude i i do i come one way
yeah i can correct i sense that about
you
you're very the attention to detail is
very [ __ ] nice i feel
yeah very nice but let's get back to
growing up so did you when you were
growing up did you have uh
brothers and sisters what'd your mom and
dad do what kind of house did you live
in et cetera et cetera
i got it so i grew up the youngest of
four
i had it went my sister kristen courtney
my brother adam then me
my mom was just taking care of us and
teaching piano lessons and then my
parents split when i was
two my mother got a job in costuming
at boston ballet and then went into
my mom's very much into the arts so was
my dad they were both music majors in
college
and like you know they both only listen
to classical music that's all i've ever
heard either of them listen to
but by the time i was 10 my dad was just
done like out of the picture gone
so that's where the right turn happened
my dad grew up like
my grandfather my dad's dad was a
physicist worked on the atom bomb
like he was at los alamos yeah worked on
the atom
i had polaroids in the other room of the
the first ever built
atom bomb that my dad gave me when i was
like 36.
so once they split my mother was still
like
we go to we go to museums we go to the
symphony we go to musicals we go to
plays we go to ballet
you don't have cable you don't have call
waiting
oh yeah she [ __ ] if someone would
call like during dinner she'd be like is
that ryan it's gonna be ryan
every time ryan um and so then my dad
was always an antique dealer my dad was
in antiques so like i've always been
into antiques
you can see oh this way that little guy
right there
charlie weaver right yeah yeah
yeah and then like the old cameras i
like old stuff ever since like my
you know i've just always liked old i
reconnected with my dad when i was 36
i saw him once so i saw him from
10 to 36 i didn't see him i saw him at
36
and then he died like five years after
that
after four years at that so then i never
saw him again but like you know i've
just always been into old stuff
and i like to i like to memorialize
things like uh
that back there is my first set list at
the comedy store and that's
everyone that was on the show with me
and then that's the check for getting
paid underneath it
that's right like i like to like yeah
yeah i take
i don't keep a ton of [ __ ] you know like
you're not going to see
posters from shows all over my place but
i'll keep something like that you know
yeah it's meaningful for you
it's pretty cle i told you before the
show that setup is pretty nice the
bookshelf
the old school record player it's
[ __ ] very classy very tight
well i will tell you this when i travel
boys i buy uh
i buy interior design art uh magazines
that's what i travel with architectural
digest
i like uh i like a hustler myself
i'm a penthouse guy listen
there's no question that you guys are
trash
[Music]
we've got to stay on brand you know what
i mean yeah
but my mom loved interior design like
that was my mom was so much of the art
so then she got into interior design
when we were older
and like i would go to like these things
like designer show houses and then my
mom ran one so like
i helped take all the doors off and like
i've always been handy like i like to
i built my kids lego table from scratch
and i just like
old stuff and i'm a firm believer like
if you're going to have a home you got
to make it a home so like
i moved to la with 3 200 in
1999 in 2000 and the first things i
bought was a dining room table a desk
you know what i mean like serving for
six
yeah yeah yeah yeah
i had a murphy bed bro at the birthday
oh nice
i like a nice murphy bed serving for six
did that dining room table have a leaf
involved was there a leaf
that went in there i love a leaf
the fact that you just said you love a
leaf you totally understand this [ __ ]
this kid's class yeah i like it
um you know what was the what was the
money like growing up
was there was there upper middle class
middle class lower class where'd you
fall
what [ __ ] money dude i don't know you
said your dad was an antique dealer
there might have been a little damn call
waiting [ __ ] is
no cash no there was no cash basically
like once that divorce happened
my dad's living and his dad my
grandfather was loaded he had a very
nice life
after working on the atom bomb he came
home and was like [ __ ] that noise
and he opened a bakery because his
grandfather had a bakery and then he
opened another one and he ended up like
doing well
so my dad didn't want to be a baker
worked in the bakery and just like
constantly was trying to get out of it
so he kind of ran that into the ground
and uh
my mom was working in a non-profit dude
if you know anything about non-profit
there's no profit no one's
no cage so we were just kind of like but
we never
like needed for anything my parents
before me had bought this great house we
lived in a four bedroom house on an acre
of land
nice they paid forty thousand dollars
for it in 1978
so my nana and my grandfather helped out
and then my two aunts
my two great aunts my mom's aunts never
married so they always helped us out
and like you know we were latchkey kids
we'd come home and either my nana would
be there or my aunt would be there and i
would just go out in the neighborhood
and play i was super into sports
you know like baseball soccer i played
all through high school i played
baseball in college
and then i did boy scouts as a kid my
mom said everyone had to do boy scouts
or girl scouts
everyone had to play an instrument and
everyone had to do sports
damn damn that's pretty good and also
too you say aunts
instead of ants that's [ __ ] pretty
that's what it is bro
yeah we say aunt aunt patty's coming
over that's what we say
did you have any answer any answer
uncles where you use their name but it
wasn't their name
no what the hell does that mean like
like like i have an aunt soupy
and i have an aunt quinny and they are
not their government names
because we're trash no aunt putties at
your house
no we had auntie brew auntie gert auntie
lill
they were all auntie lil lived to 102
auntie brew 100 auntie gert 98.
it sounds like your mom really put a
good head on all your shoulders like she
really like
[ __ ] kept her head down you know kept
all the demons away and
and [ __ ] and pushed through
she did she gave us everything but love
yeah it was very
uh familiar with those kind of
households yeah why she was a little
cold
yeah i mean dude
you guys obviously don't have kids right
no no
not that i know do you like that do you
like that subtle dig by the way
you obviously don't have kids i picked
up on it larson
i finger banged a couple of chicks
i'm pretty sure the state would relieve
[Laughter]
him
uh what was the question again um
i forget we were talking about your oh
your mom though you're my you said she
gave you everything but love
yeah about love she was she was little
so i have two kids and the amount of
energy
i think you need to pour into a human
being to actually
give them the love that you can like
support them
you can also like challenge them you can
also
make not baby them it takes so much
to do all of that and i have two kids
and that's so much work for two
when you get to four and there's no no
one else to help
and you're working full-time there's
right no capacity
yeah like i realized recently i said to
my brother we were talking i go
i go dude do you realize how low the bar
was in our house
that mom gets so much credit just for
staying
yeah she stayed that's it sticking
around
you know at the same time my mom gave us
values and
and really impressed upon us the arts
and like
culture for sure and i love that because
to this day i'm like
man what will my life be you know
without it you know because i
i really enjoy it not just because she
put it upon us because now i've like
found such an appreciation for it and
now i i
push it upon my kids and they they love
it that's awesome
yeah that's pretty classy i can tell you
you're starting off the gate [ __ ]
bat in a thousand i [ __ ] like it
classy individual dude where did you
what are you
so i really wanted to impress you like
it was
really important to me you saw his
hawaiian shirt you're like i gotta win
this guy over i want him on my team
yeah if you need tickets to the opera
next time you're in new york let me know
i'll uh
i'll scalp a couple for you all right
[Laughter]
all right this one is this is a question
that's it's recurring on the podcast the
past couple of weeks
yeah he's very different a little are
you garbage here um do you brush your
teeth in the shower
oh yeah every single day now do you want
to know why
why you want to know why [ __ ] time
management i got two minutes to brush my
teeth there you go
i got an electric you know mine's
powered it goes four increments of 30
seconds that's two minutes
when i get in the shower i'm into water
conservation okay i like to conserve
water so i
get in i'm lathering while i'm brushing
okay as long as if so because some
people do it they just stand there and
they just brush their teeth and
that's not time management you can be
standing in the [ __ ] living room you
know what i mean
but if you're lathering while you're
brushing i'll i'll let it slide a little
bit
do you keep the toothbrush in the shower
or do you have it outside of the shower
after i brush my teeth it goes next to
like over where the shampoo
is and then when we're at bedtime when i
go to brush again
i go how am i being judged by youtube
[ __ ]
because you're brushing your teeth in
the shower and you keep the toothbrush
in there there's all kinds of particles
flying around
i'm going to give you something else i'm
gonna i'm gonna give you an element
of the shower dynamic that you might
think is garbage
and i'm gonna tell you it's class okay
when i own my own home because i don't
own my own home
the first thing i am putting in is an
outdoor shower and i will take a shower
out there
every day yeah outdoor showers like
you're just gonna
yeah i'm gonna nice little fence around
it with i'm gonna grow some ivy around
it sit out there in the afternoon
see the neighbor charlie
charlie i'm brushing my teeth in here
you're not gonna believe it i got two
minutes so the kids come knocking on the
door
it gets so crazy people floss in there
too people will floss in the in the
shower which i find is
is crazy to me but you know that's their
own that might be a little much
yeah for sure for sure all right let's
go back to your uh your childhood a
little bit what was the name of the
street that you grew up on
i can't give that out okay fair enough
i'm just kidding
i'm kidding [ __ ] it scared me for a
second
oh oak street that's like a classic
american
that's like a you know one two three
main street anytown usa yeah cause we do
a lot of judgment on that you know if
you grew up on a road
or something like that or a [ __ ]
freeway turnpike or something
yeah we had josh potter on here and he
grew up on like [ __ ] uh
like stephen's drive-through or some
[ __ ] like that yeah it was like a
through
he said he could see it he said he could
see a toll booth from his house
he's like that's never a good sign just
based on
footage that i've seen i don't think
josh potter can see 10 feet in front
it's real very true i don't know
at the end of the driveway boom oak oak
tree right now wow
that's pretty close that's a good
american upbringing right there nice and
what was the name of the grocery store
that your mother went to when you were
growing up
stock market kid stomach
market yes [ __ ] stat markets stat mac
and super i mean i don't even know if
they're still around
i think they are we just had somebody
else a couple weeks ago that was from uh
new england and they said they said they
their family still goes to stab markets
i think
yeah let me just tell you this too we
were like a very loyal family like
i don't know my mom probably instilled
this in me as well
but like when the stop and shop went in
our town
we were like [ __ ] no way for sure until
we die
yeah dude yeah and we i remember
distinct like i'm all about mom and pop
shops i only
not only but like that's my focus i'd
say
90 of the time i'm at a mom and pop and
this
walgreens went into our town and it
literally took out across the street the
family pharmacy that had been there
it took it out in like a month and a
half and i remember like i've been to
that walgreens one time and i was like
never again
never again bro yeah no i've never been
to a walmart
why are you on the road or anything you
never hit a walmart never been
never been to a walmart [ __ ] i ate at a
walmart two nights ago
i don't think they made their own bread
either i had dinner there i'll tell you
that
that's a i took a date there bro
[Laughter]
didn't close unfortunately um uh
i don't know why i don't know nah i like
dude you're coming up
coming up classy man coming up pretty
pretty pretty classy
yeah i like it have you ever been a part
of a focus group
yes oh what was the situation you ready
for it
yeah you ready for this dude i was
getting ready to move to la
i was trying to save money to move to la
i had no money actually i was flunked
out of college flunked out of college
what college if you don't mind me asking
what college
saint anselm college in new hampshire
liberal arts school
i got back in graduated anyway
[Laughter]
no big deal my sister
was is very smart did very well in
school she worked at a hospital in
boston and she was like
hey they're doing this uh this clinical
trial for mouthwash for cancer patients
you know you get paid 50 dollars for the
first time in
50 for the second and then the sleepover
you get 500.
done this this is where the
this is where the true garbage comes in
oh yeah on this
on the sleepover i
called this is how old school it was i
call my home
phone to check the voicemail see if
anyone called me
and the only message on there is from
the funeral home
telling us hey we got your grandmother
uh to my mom we have your mom we she's
in good care blah blah blah my
grandmother died that night that i was
at this thing jesus so i get the i get
the news
my sister comes into her office the next
day i'm sleeping in that wing and i'm
like hey
and i had to tell her and then after we
get done
she was like oh there's i have more bad
news and i go what and she's like
your blood work came back for the the
trial and
there was marijuana in your blood
i didn't get the five hundy
not even 250 for spending the night what
the [ __ ]
dude it even cut me off a honeybee
a honeybee oh that's [ __ ] that's like
wet in your beak
come on man unqualified for a [ __ ]
dude that's [ __ ] i did i did one not
too long ago
like a few years ago i did one in new
york i was hard up for cash
and i went and it was like something for
some streaming service [ __ ] and i
sat in like the mirrored room and [ __ ]
and uh
you feel like a [ __ ] you feel like you
have power like i'm like yeah i would
never buy this service you know
meanwhile i'm using like my aunt's
[ __ ] netflix like i'm not paying for
any service to begin with
but on the way dude on the way out they
hit me with a hundred and fifty dollar
which i thought it was 150 cage they hit
me with a 150 dollar gift card i'm like
i can't
i [ __ ] i can't pay rent with a visa
gift card what are we doing
see i would have looked at that this is
how garbage i am i would have been like
i could pond this for a hundy i know but
i needed the 150. i was
i was hemmed up in a bad spot
totally totally but the the worst part
is guys i'm testing positive for weed
at my sister's tri it's like her
she has to go to her co-workers and be
like yeah my brother's out you know
that's the chibichiva you know what i
mean patient 32b
is uh disqualified the kids got glaucoma
oh that's good oh that is too funny
huh uh all right and with college what
did you get on your sats that's a big
one on those
yeah what'd you get i got 10 60.
meaty part of the curve nice one and
done you know you got to get over that
thousand hump you know
that's it dude that if you could get in
the four digits it was [ __ ] get that
and take a hike see
what were the circumstances that flunked
out of college was just strictly bad
grades
yeah what do you not know about flunking
out of college he shouldn't
know like we don't we don't like his ad
you get either flunk out or you get
kicked out i got flunk though
kicked out is like oh you beat someone
up you know all right so it wasn't so
what was your gpa that semester well so
first semester freshman year i got four
c's and a b not bad second semester
yeah second semester i got a 1.0
which is like i failed two classes and i
got a d and then they let me come back
and i got another 1.0 and they were like
all right peace yeah yeah a similar
situation happened to me my first
semester i was an english major but i
was playing football at this division
three school
and they like ran the school uh widener
university in southeastern pennsylvania
and uh okay i was an english major i got
a .2
my freshman year first semester so then
they made me
change uh they made me the football
coaches sat me down there was like
seven of us lined up in front of the
coach's office at the end of the
semester where they made us all go in
and [ __ ] call all our teachers and
begged them to give us a d
nobody would do it for me so i was going
to get flunked out so i had to change
the [ __ ] hotel and restaurant
management
for the next semester
and let me tell you something it ain't
the cream of the crop in that [ __ ]
school i'll tell you that
ray kroc when you named off your school
i knew it wasn't the cream of any crop
yeah and then it gives you he doesn't
even say it's in pennsylvania
philadelphia hit you with southeastern
pennsylvania like who
magellan relax over here all right no
one no one wants to go to your school
one of the kids on my baseball team in
college my buddy bill
it was senior second semester he wasn't
going to graduate
and like they grade on a curve at my
school so like the
60 of the class gets a c and then you
know
20 percent a b 20 dc sure df
so he he was gonna flunk and not
graduate so he goes to this teacher and
he's like
yo he's flunking he's like you got to
give me a b or i'm not going to graduate
and the teacher was like are you already
[ __ ] out and he's like you gotta
like i there's nothing i can do the guy
was like
i'll give you the b get out of my face i
never want to see you again but
that b was contingent upon another
teacher he had to go to
that he had to get to give him a c and
that teacher was like [ __ ] you you're
getting a d
that's it so he went back to the other
teacher
and got an ah
the teacher was like i never want to see
you
ever again hey see you to reunion huh
[Laughter]
still hang out for homecoming am i right
but maybe we'll do a drink or something
alright i'm on my weekend
okay that's classic dude
oh that is [ __ ] awesome huh
hey what's up everybody today's episode
is brought to you by
sheath underwear sheath makes the
softest most comfortable boxer briefs i
have ever worn and i got them on
right now if you're sick of boxers that
are too loose or briefs that are too
tight
sheath is for you here's what makes
sheath unique
it's a stretchy fabric it's made out of
moisture wicking technology
it feels silky and keeps everything cool
comfortable and in place
it's the perfect underwear for working
out
plus the most unique thing about sheath
underwear is they have these dual
pouches they keep your man parts
separated keep the franks away from the
beans
which prevents them from sticking
together
this is huge for working out or being in
hot environments or if you just want to
make the fall activities a little more
enjoyable
you know we'll make pumpkin picking a
little more fun making sure your balls
aren't on your thighs you know what i
mean
sheath underwear will make that happen
for you
no more chafing no more gross ball sweat
just comfort and support for your boys
now for some of you might not be
interested in separating your man parts
i still recommend sheath you can wear
them like any other boxer brief
and they're crazy comfortable and i want
to say you might not even know you need
your man part separated but once you
separate
them there's no going back there's
either go in the pouch out of the patch
someone together some of them separate
whatever you want to do there's a lot of
options
uh and one more thing these look good on
you i call them my sexy underwear i put
a pair on and make a move on my wife uh
and sheath makes it look like you're
packing or if you are packing it makes
you look like you're really really
packing so for me it just looks like i'm
backing
so go to sheathunderwear.com to get a
pair of the most comfortable underwear
you will
ever own and if you use the code garbage
that's g-a-r-b-a-g-e you'll get twenty
percent off your order
twenty percent off your order go do it
that sheath underwear dot com
and use the code garbage for 20 off now
back
to the show uh growing up did uh
did your mom ever cut your hair
my sister cut my hair once my mother
never did okay
all right and i'll give you this is this
will give you an idea of where
my mom wanted us to go and where we were
going in eighth grade
i was i was in good shape you know i'm
not in great shape now but i was in
really good shape then and
my mom got me an uh an
interview to model for benetton do you
remember benaton yeah
the united colors of you know what i'm
saying son
[ __ ] that was gonna be my trip to
just [ __ ] hot chicks so
i was gonna go into ton on like tuesday
right
and on saturday night we had like a
sleepover everyone on the soccer team i
was on the soccer team we
all decided let's like do crazy haircuts
so i
shaved the sides of my head put lines
down the side and then
lines coming out and on saturday morning
my or sunday morning my mother was going
out
i don't know where she was going and i
was on the phone my girlfriend
so she walked by me comes back an hour
later i'm still on the phone and
actually comes in sees the back of my
head
and she loses it you were supposed to go
in for benatar
so that's how trash i was i was just
like nah man [ __ ]
eighth grade soccer baby yeah i brain
supreme over [ __ ] ben pentatons dude
you know what i mean bennett was pretty
classy i was a fragrance model for
over one christmas break for ckb
remember ckb
i remember ck once yeah it was the
shitty version of ck1
that came out ck 1.5
what do you mean you were friggin smart
people could just come up and smell you
is that what it is no i would stand
there and hand out the little cards with
with with the spray
that's not a model dude that is far from
what it said on my tax return i was a
model
for a little while you were not a model
that's right
that's some [ __ ] my mom would do my
neighbor my neighbor tom
helped me always help us out because
there was no man there so like when we
got old
he moved in when i was older and he'd
help my mom with tons of stuff and he
used to
i remember like being away in la and
going home to visit and i was like
what's going on buddy and he's like
nothing we're hanging on his porch
having beers i'm like how's my mom he's
like dude your mom's like
she's got champagne taste on a beer
budget you know what i mean i'm like
yeah
that is my mom so she would be like now
did you know that my son
is a fragrance mom that would be my mom
really trying to church it up it's like
nah dude you're handing out you're
handing out [ __ ] pamphlets at the
macy's relax you might as well be
spinning the sign
yeah exactly [ __ ] she says you're a chef
you're handing out rock and roll samples
at the mall
[Laughter]
he made the chicken teriyaki it's
delicious you should try it's
unbelievable that's uh that's a
recurring question on the show as well
if you were
it would say say it's lunchtime you're
hungry and you're at a mall food court
what are you getting uh
i mean let me tell you something when it
comes to food i use it as a healing
thing i use it as a celebration i'm not
like good at food
so like honestly it could go a number of
ways i could see myself hit
i'll give you a couple options i can see
myself hitting mickey d's for
number one and a cheeseburger kicker and
then swing by
a couple maybe maybe i hit d
d for like a boston cream and a cruella
you know what i mean coffee for the rug
if they got a sparrow i might grab a
slice of cheese
dude the slices from sabaro are huge
that's the classiest one
i might knock down panda king for a
little orange chicken and some noodles
i mean whatever it is i would do there
is like
a food court to me and i'm not in the
muffin
is like a dirty little secret yeah you
have no idea what i'm going to do over
here
it's anonymous yeah yeah i'll bring a
cheeseboard to your dinner party but you
put me in a food court
and [ __ ] it's like garbage in me just
explode oh yeah
it's like they're all equal in there i
like how you said the cheeseburger
kicker because i take a lot of [ __ ]
because i always get the meal but then i
i refer to it as a walking around burger
i get something to [ __ ] take with me
on the road they don't go in the bag
he's wearing it out you know what i mean
that bro when i used to go to dunkin
donuts i would go in i'd be like let me
get a ham and cheese croissant
i get an iced coffee and i go and let me
grab a chocolate honey dip
and they go okay and i go yeah you don't
need to put i'm going to eat it while i
while i wait is what i mean yeah i like
the you you change the
the wordage to let me grab off like it's
not i'll take that let me get
let me get that now and then we can
finish the rest of the [ __ ] process
yeah that's like wearing the sneakers
out of foot locker [ __ ] put the old
ones in the box i'm wearing these
puppies
out through the [ __ ] front door 100
100
so obviously from being new england
you're you're a d d guy you're a dunkin
donuts guy you're not a starbucks guy
uh well now i'm not on any of those
things guy
i like to just go to like all local
spots
like i said i like mom and pop like when
i go on the road one of my favorite
things to do is find like
the the the dope coffee shop and go kick
it and get coffee like it just becomes
part of my routine yeah i love that
going
up and write and stuff yeah d and d
i would take over but i would d and d i
never
excuse me you weren't thinking about how
good the coffee was at d
and d you know what i mean nor do i
think starbucks has good coffee
they're they're both d and d i just go
because like that's my
you know those are the best donuts in
the world i go for donuts you know
yeah i tell you what dunkin donuts man
they make a pretty mean [ __ ] bacon
egg and cheese on a croissant too
and i don't know what they put in those
[ __ ] tate and those uh those hash
browns
but those are [ __ ] michelin rated
those are fantastic
dude i've had them like couple times
because when are you getting hash
hash browns and dunkin donuts and i said
the same thing i was like
i was at an airport i was embarrassed to
even be like [ __ ]
on point dude i don't know what the
seasoning is but those things are
[ __ ]
little gold little pieces of gold yeah
they're nice yeah for sure
um all right i got one at any point were
you were you ever a velveeta shells in
cheese household now
or then you eat me like just straight
mac and cheese
yeah like proper velveeta shells and
cheese or were you a craft family yeah
velveeta is the classiest because it's
got the real cheese real
is this is debatable no it's yeah no
it's not
anything it is you can buy off the shelf
bro
is it a space-age sealed package what
are you talking about
that's real cheese all right let me give
you two
let me give you i'll give you two things
on this one we were
a definite mac and cheese family because
like like i said we didn't have a lot of
money
not only did we not have a lot of money
my grandmother
she was old when she she was 40 when she
had my mom
so my nana and her two sisters
and her sister-in-law who all raised us
they were all
they all survived the depression you
know what i mean so
dude you want you know what my nana used
to kick out on wednesday nights
mac and cheese mixed with tuna you ever
do that
oh tuna cake that's what a casserole
and then it's baked then she bakes that
[ __ ] and that's
i'm not talking tuna tuna with mayo
mixed with cooked mac and cheese
so we were a craft family i never had
velveeta
but then my wife uh during thanksgiving
every year
and christmas make casserole with
velveeta it's all melted in right
so then my tradition started being when
i would be cooking
for thanksgiving or christmas dinner
like during the day i would take that
velveeta
and my lunch would be a grilled cheese
with that velveeta
nothing bad wow i never did that damn
that's something else yeah nothing
better than that
did you guys uh did you do hot dogs when
you were a kid with your big hot dog
family
of course bro now would you have the hot
dogs
go ahead go ahead i'm gonna one-up you
because i know what you're gonna ask and
i'm already know where i'm going go
all right so one of the things that we
have is there's levels of garbage for
the hot dogs
uh the shittiest would be boiling them
second would be
doing them in the skillet all right
third would be doing them in the skillet
but sliced open
and third would be the classiest on the
grill how would you guys prepare your
hot dogs
bro i'm about to make ayg
history right now and i'm going to take
it to the most
you want to know what we would do go in
the fridge take it out and eat it
straight
up what the [ __ ] another one you're a
cold hot dog
guy they're pre-cooked bro
they gotta be heated up dude come on
so listen to me we
we never had the grill dude single mom
there's no grill i didn't have a grill
until college and
friends had grills and i was like oh
like i never had a grill
and i remember like when i finally had a
grill in la
like my my roommate got one i was like
oh grilling you know
so i boil my kids hot dogs for them
if i can if i if i saute them they hate
them
they hate it really yeah it has a weird
taste to a kid i used to like them
boiled too
dude we were say oh sorry no go go go
i was just saying we we would boil them
in the we would go like we'd go to the
jersey shore for the weekend or whatever
and we would boil them like in a small
motel room
and then put them in a cooler of hot
water and take them to the beach
and then like [ __ ] fish them out like
we were hot dog vendors and like put
them like
it was looking back it was attractive
terrible dude
kraut you want crowd
[Laughter]
give me two a crowd in a yoo-hoo
going to say this about hot dogs i can
eat a hot dog
grilled cut open i don't give a [ __ ] oh
yeah this is another thing my nana would
do my nana would cook the hot dogs cook
mac and cheese
and then put the hot dogs in and like
another one
yeah that's another one she would do
that's something else though that's a
good one
i love [ __ ] what do you put on your
hot dog i go playing jane
straight up playing i'll dabble ketchup
mustard
uh if i'm getting it from a guy you know
from from a you know a uh
you know vendor a vendor i'm doing kraut
there's definitely gonna be kraut
um and if it's a place that does it good
i'll get i'll do a chili dog
all right let me ask you though what's
your mustard choice bro this is big for
me
on a hot dog here's the thing all right
uh
you still looking nice with me dude you
seem like a nice guy you're a good kid
uh between you and i and kippy uh
i go regular yellow mustard yeah me too
i'm straight up yellow mustard anytime i
go to a vendor in new york i lived there
for a year and a half and i'd be like
i get dogs all it's just like the
easiest thing
yeah and and i go do you have yellow
mustard and they go yeah
and i take the thing and it'd be brown
mustard i'm like dude just cause this is
yellow this is not yellow bro
i need ketchup yellow mustard maybe
relish i don't know i'll do kraut maybe
time to time
if you got the extra nickel yeah [ __ ]
live it up a little bit
yeah you got to do you got to do i'm a
big mustard guy like i
i like all different kinds of mustard
all right i consider myself a foodie
but i wouldn't put [ __ ] grape on
he is not a foodie i don't know what i
wouldn't put grey coupon on a hot dog it
just doesn't work
yeah i mean i might [ __ ] with it a
little bit i'll do that on sausage and
stuff
i do want to say the fact kevin that uh
you go playing jane leads me to believe
that if ever authorities came to me and
they're like hey
uh this guy murdered three people we
think
do you know anything about him i'm like
that guy eats plain hot dog the guy eats
plain hot dogs
that's your guy dude all right well now
don't get me wrong if i go to papaya dog
get the recession special with the two
dogs and the drink for five bucks
i'll do maybe i'll do some ketchup or
some chili cheese whatever but yeah
we're not animals
i like a nice just clean no frills
dog you know what i mean or you know
what there's nothing clean
there's nothing clean that's why you put
all the [ __ ] on it it is not clean
you know what i grew up and i'll still
do i don't buy them because i'm i'm
married now like it would never
[ __ ] fly in the household but i would
get the oscar meyer hot dogs with the
cheese already in them the cheese dogs
throw two of them in the microwave for a
minute good [ __ ] night jay larson
yeah cheese dogs not bad not bad on an
oscar mayer cheese dog
that is [ __ ] trash
two martin's potato rolls called a
[ __ ] day
well oh potato rolls for sure yeah
potato rolls are [ __ ] classy all the
way
all right let's stay on food here for a
minute i still can't get a reader i'm
saying he's class
yeah it's i mean honestly you know the
bacon you're i mean i think baking your
own bread and taking it to a [ __ ]
dinner party is like that's
you know there's signs of it there's
signs of garbage
let's let's find out about now like how
are you how are you with the kids as far
as their snacks now
do you find yourself resorting back to
the things that you grew up on that
you're giving the kids now
or have you kind of shied away from that
heritage
i mean put it this way we went i took
them camping just me and them this
weekend
and friday night i made pasta
right with tomato sauce and cut
cucumbers
and then for breakfast the next day i
made scrambled eggs and they
i gave them each a pumpkin muffin for
lunch she had ham roll ups
just ham rolled up he had a peanut
butter and jelly they both had carrots
and chips and then that night for dinner
i made
sauteed onions zucchini and squash
with rice for me and her with steak and
i made him
steak and i made hand-cut french fries
from a potato
oh mom this guy's [ __ ] clear bougie
morris both nights you know we did
s'mores both nights
i like to cook though and i looked at it
i'm like if you're car
camping you know michael costa yeah of
course
costa's got one of the greatest jokes he
talks about how like you
pack differently when you're flying
versus driving
and he's like when you're flying you'll
be like
should i bring this belt like i don't
have room for this belt he goes but when
you're like
and i'm i'm taking liberty with this
joke and then he's like but when you're
driving you're like hey babe should we
bring a blender
just like whip up smoothies in the hotel
room you know
so when you're like camping you can pull
your car up to the site and i have a
giant cooler so i was like
oh i can make all this stuff yeah who
makes spaghetti when you're camping
though what the [ __ ] is that all about
money
my kids don't like hamburgers yet like i
could have busted out hot dogs but i'm
like what's the point you know like my
daughter loves pasta
and i really wanted to make it like uh i
wanted the first time they camped
everything to just
kick you know what i mean so that they
liked it so that they were like oh it's
so fun and then the next time you know i
don't have to go crazy you know
right but um but do you give them
cookies
do you pre-cook the pasta or are you
cooking hard pasta there over the
fire i got a [ __ ] stove i got a
little propane stove bro
you think he's [ __ ] pre-making pasta
i didn't know
who is [ __ ] spaghetti when you're
camping this guy's [ __ ] clown so you
brought forks and stuff like that that's
pretty classy
yeah i don't like to use a lot of
plastic bro i kind of like to take
care of the environment you know the
fact that you guys are drinking water
out of plastic cups right now is a
little bit of an insult
i carry this around with me for all the
listeners i take this everywhere i go
it's glass too we blew it ourselves it's
dude that's [ __ ] you know what that
is glassy bro
um so but like at the same time like you
know we had s'mores every night i
brought oreo cookies i brought chips and
guac
you know what i mean so like nice i just
my kids
love they love carrots cucumbers
they eat broccoli green beans i want
them to love veggies because guests
listen do i want my kids to look like
the three of us when they're all right
no not no no your attention to detail
is second to none pretty nice saying
that's the second thing that's a real
classy move right there
um damn all right you know like i in
stand-up
i was like always came from the world of
like specificity like the more specific
i could be
like i used to tell like young comics
i'm like listen if you told a story on
stage how you went to
a movie with your friend versus you went
to a movie
with your friend dave the george what's
going to get a little
you're you're letting people in so like
i always am very
detail-oriented and very specific
because it's just like
the little extra steps like i remember
one day my buddy goes
dude with kids who has time to like cook
pancakes on a weekday and i'm like
i got a [ __ ] waffle maker bro i mean
i throwing the [ __ ] down over here so
you're definitely not trash now
yeah no no i don't i mean i mean trust
me dude i made a real
strong choice to go pick up this
vietnamese food versus going to bk
getting a number eight that's the
original chicken sandy
with fries i go large give me two sides
of ranch and i do a cheeseburger kicker
they got the new jalapeno papas they're
just not doing it like jack in the box
i've had those jalapeno poppers over
there they ain't bad but we don't have
jack in the box out here
yeah i think you'll survive right um
have you ever ordered stuffed crust
pizza
never have do you get omaha steaks
delivered to your house
only when they were a sponsor on my
podcast okay
fair enough have you ever kept the
coolers
kept a what kept the coolers that the
omaha steaks have you ever used the
omaha steaks coolers
for any other purpose than the steaks
being delivered
nah bro okay but i did buy a vintage
cooler at a at a yard sale once
that's pretty close [ __ ] cold was it
a coleman
nah it was like this awesome brown it
looked like military style and it had
like
the cooler top that flipped this way and
that way dude oh that's pretty sweet
you got some cool [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
cooler with the suicide doors that's
pretty classy right there
it's got the rolls-royce of [ __ ]
coolers got the winged doors like a
[ __ ] delorean
dude yeah i like that
have you ever ordered a screwdriver at
the bar
uh have i ever got a screwdriver uh
that's not a bad drink i've probably had
one before yeah but that wouldn't be my
go-to
i mean when i was drinking drinking i
started
like uh i used to go soco kettle one
citron rocks then i would go soco rocks
then i went to maker's rocks and then i
got so into whiskies
i was like you know i used to host a
drinking show with sean patton
oh that's right yeah the best bars right
so right yeah yeah yeah
i've i've drank everything so like i
would get a vodka crayon that's like the
most
underrated drink yeah
that's not that's a great it's such a
massachusetts cape cod thing getting a
cape cod
bro yeah it's not showing off either you
know what i mean
it's nice listen yeah
all right i got one for you here um
have you uh the christmas time you guys
celebrate christmas
we do yeah oh you probably [ __ ]
killed what's the decorations what's the
decoration
situation now on the tree are they
colored lights are they white lights
all right so growing up we were a white
light family it was all white lights
that's very good because your mom's
classy is your mom's classy yeah
and my mom not only she also went into
like um
she like my mom did pottery and she made
a chandelier so she made a bunch of
ornaments
and then part of her like christmas
tradition was every year we go to my
aunt rose house and everyone could pick
an ornament off her tree for archery to
keep
and she used to travel because she was
never married so she would get ornaments
everywhere she went
so dope so my mom always went white
lights we always went fake tree no
dad fake tree sure and then one year her
friend
gave us on her fake tree which was super
nice
that went in the living room and the
other fake tree went in the breezeway i
don't know if you know what a breezeway
is what the hell is it
oh but i know i can't afford it that's
the room between the garage and the
house man that's the breezeway
you know it's not like insulated it's
like a three season porch kind of vibe
so we had a bonus tree in there now
in our house we've always done a real
tree you know
last christmas i said i'm done with real
trees
i'm getting this fake tree you know i
just don't understand it do you ever go
buy a christmas tree lot
when the year's over and there's like 40
trees and you're like what the [ __ ]
what was the point of this yeah i'm
gonna use my tree for 25
30 years you know what i mean i don't
know it just doesn't make sense to me it
doesn't have the same smell though
it doesn't have the pineapple it's a
spray dude
this guy's got tree cologne what the
[ __ ] that's [ __ ]
trash he's a cologne model
that is trash dude street cologne you're
garb
spraying it with pine sol and [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] no and then uh but we go yeah
we go all out
i go all out i bake cookies during the
season you know what i mean i miss snow
so i'm gonna try and take the kids up to
the mountains this christmas
like at least around the holiday you
know um
i do i have fantasies about about owning
like 100 acres in western mass and then
getting a horse with the sleigh yeah i
do
i'm an anheuser-busch commercial [ __ ]
robert frost over here i like it
right go ahead please
i was gonna say i'm more like a ralph
waldo emerson
very nice he is my favorite of the
transcendentalists you know what i mean
it goes emerson thoreau
whitman probably sure big fan of on
walden pond
uh then i got one in this realm what is
the last book you read
uh well i've been reading with my k do
you want
you ready for this bro dion sanders dion
on dion
by dion sanders dude are you ready for
this
i couldn't have call waiting my best
friend growing up ryan young
shout out to rye dog cy young he his
parents gave him his own line
so they had those kids so he got to pick
his number
because in my town and you know what he
picked
his number was two seven nine two one
two
four and we were like why two one two
four he goes dion dion bro
dion dion 21 21 football 24 baseball he
was 24 on the braves or whatever
um but what was the question again
the last book you read yeah last book oh
so i've been reading like i want my kids
to really
appreciate reading because like it's
just like a lost
it's just getting lost on people now
like the fact that you read
you know everyone's like well we listen
to books with our kids and we we listen
to them and i'm like
oh yeah that is not the same thing i i i
just love reading with them
so they're six he's six she's five now
and we've read the first three harry
potters all three of them damn
but now now it's starting getting a
little adult so we stopped
so during the black lives matter
movement i really looked at myself and
was like yo
you need to like really start giving
more information and enlightening your
kids about this [ __ ] so
we looked up black businesses in la and
we found this bookstore called
uh malik books the black owned bookstore
and all the books
are black authors or black content we
went there and i was like
hey i need i need new books outside of
harry potter
and they gave us this great book called
um
uh what's it called it's something in
the queen i can't remember but it's
it's this book that i read with the kids
that's the last book i i'm not reading
my own books anymore i'm reading
to them with them yeah but it's a it's a
dope book
written kobe bryant actually helped make
this series of books
oh [ __ ] so i wish i could think of it
but
anyway yeah that was the last book
that's pretty [ __ ] classy
i was looking for like superman source
you know something
i was never into i was into like uh you
know like all back here that's all like
uh
i got into the beats a lot and
transcendentalists and you know like
the invisible man and and [ __ ] like that
i just
i don't know that was kind of like where
i fell in [ __ ] sharp dude i know
[ __ ] sharp dude uh we just got a
couple more questions for you we're
gonna get you out of here
i just want to hit you with a couple of
the standards that we do here um
a big one would be growing up or now did
you have milk with dinner as a kid
yes do you give as a kid not
they get water a ton they'll do i'll he
takes oj at night
i mean in the morning she has milk but
like every now and then i'm like i'll
kick that milk at dinner but it's almost
always water
yeah do you and you don't do it now
right do you
still drink milk dude there's grown most
it's this is the most divisive
he they all all there these grown men in
their 30s and 40s
will make a bowl of pasta and then get
like a glass of whole milk
it's always pasta and red sauce that
they like with the milk it's so weird
great
it's trashy it is the trashiest thing
you can do yeah
that's a broken childhood
[Laughter]
yeah man vargasi does that great joke
where he goes to starbucks and he goes
to pick up his drink and it's like a
milk over ice and he's like what
am i a serial killer yeah yeah yeah
do you keep your butter on the counter
or in the fridge
it's fridge i do like that butter i do
like that counter move though that is
tight
yeah i was against it i was i was
staunchly against i we were butter in
the fridge household
uh and then we just found out last week
that it's actually because
you can leave salted butter out for like
toast and bagels and whatever
yeah unsalted butter stays in the fridge
because it's cooking so you can leave
the [ __ ] in you can start start today go
get rabbit thing as a stick of butter
and leave it out start live a little bit
here's the thing though dude i'm
strictly on a spread now
non-dairy non-butter spread what country
croc what are you [ __ ] with
crocus butter bro isn't it no it's like
chemical i don't know what
it's not yeah it's not soybean or
something some commie [ __ ] my kids gets
[Laughter]
uh but the kids get straight up butter i
used to love that move we had the butter
dish and stuff as a kid but like what we
would do is we go over just grab hunks
of it and just eat it
that's what i'm talking about seeing a
little garbage peek through there made
my blood run
i see a little garbage behind you behind
that chair
by the way this chair is uh mid-century
dutch
that was bought in amsterdam flown over
wow damn you're flying chairs over
i didn't fight i got a i got a i got a
furniture guy i go
you got a [ __ ] chair furniture guys i
got a furniture guy dude
holy [ __ ] what else you got kip i think
that's it for me i mean
you know he think he started like he
started off a little rocky but
you know we didn't ask you do you think
you're garbage no
right um i i have identity crisis when
it comes to this like
i put it this way this is i told you
guys i t to the line
and i don't even want to share this idea
because someone will take it but i do
have dreams of opening
like a little bodega like but like a
country style
like where we sell only like local wines
and i have a little floral section but
like great sandwiches
but i want to have it that if if you
order a chicken
sandwich right or order a breakfast
sandwich for me this is how we'll go
down so
someone asked me for hey what's up man
what can i get this is this is foley's
world of the podcast
hey man what can i get you hey buddy can
i grab the um
the sausage egg and cheese on the uh on
the ciabatta
no you just asked for a breakfast
sandwich bro okay listen we're not
[ __ ]
mixing matching here i'm going to show
you how it goes down in my joint right
asking for a bake
let me get a bacon egg and cheese no you
just say i want a [ __ ] i want a
breakfast saver all right we didn't get
the script take it easy
i sent it over in my preliminary preview
hey mr larson can i have a can i have a
breakfast sandwich please
two breakfast sandwiches please you want
those blue collar or bougie
blue collar so the whole menu would be
blue collar of bougie so a blue collar
breakfast sandwich would be english
muffin
fried egg bacon cheese
out the door the bougie is brioche bun
fried egg with the with the whole yolk
maybe some arugula tossed a little
vinaigrette
with like a like a nice maybe i'm not a
bree fan but maybe like
a havati maybe like a havati on there
you know what i mean so everything which
would be like
blue collar or bougie sure that's
fantastic
and the blue collar sandwich is like
five and the bougie is like
11. you know dude that's [ __ ]
something else that's a pretty good one
and i
i think that this is my theory uh i
think that you're so
staunchly not garbage now because you
know
garbage yeah you go i'm not going to be
that guy i'm going to have the nice this
i'm going to
i'm going to do this right i've got
dutch chairs yeah you're doing
everything right because you know the
dark side
i think yeah i know where it can go i
know where you can end up yeah yeah yeah
see the other side of this [ __ ] we
walked home from soccer practice you
know
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ] ladies and gentlemen mr j
larson i'm going to say
100 percent class my friend you're all
class in our mind
classy [ __ ] guy for sure
[Music]
especially with the [ __ ] trash bags
we've had on this show you look like a
[ __ ] kennedy
without the dead bodies trust me trust
me i got a kennedy bust up here on the
he's not 10 is it
no i do shop for kennedy bus there's an
antique mart i like to go to and there's
this guy's one stall and he's got
kennedy busts you know it's a big
collector's thing the fact that you're
shopping for busts
most 99 of comedians wouldn't even know
what the [ __ ] a bust is
and you're you're shopping for them this
guy's [ __ ] classy
all class brother uh before we let you
out of here is there anything you want
the folks out there to know you got
anything coming up that you want to
promote
where they can where we can direct them
to
um semi retired from stand up that's
probably going to continue for at least
a year
and i'm just writing and uh i'm
directing a couple things stuff like
that but uh no
nothing to promote awesome we'll enjoy
your lives and spend time with your
loved ones oh see look at that [ __ ]
heartfelt and everything
too jay larson ladies and gentlemen 100
class kippy what are you going to tell
them out there
as always make sure you rate review
subscribe on itunes full video available
on youtube you can subscribe there as
well
um go to gastidialnetwork.com you can
sign up use promo code ayg
and i'm at kevin ryan comedy on all
social media and at age foley on ice and
foleygrams on instagram
uh jay we appreciate you coming on the
show man thank you so much yeah thank
you fantastic
super fun you guys i really appreciate
you having me and i i hope you guys keep
crushing it
thank you buddy folks we'll see you
later thank you
thank you man that was awesome this uh